[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
DR. GAIN: So today we are going
to talk about the evolution
of water resources management.
And at the end of
the class, you will
be able to describe paradigm
shift and evolution of water
resources management in general.
But also, you can
critically evaluate
the importance of IWRM
for water diplomacy,
and also Water-Energy-Food nexus
and its relation with water
diplomacy, and also
importance of water diplomacy
for achieving sustainable
development goals.
Today's talk is
regarding a new process--
recent-- a process
of water resources
management and sustainable
development goals
and its relation with
our water diplomacy.
In this figure, I
try to summarize
taken from these references
how the water resource
management has evolved
throughout the time.
It has four metrics.
You can see that from the
centralized management
to decentralized management
in the vertical axis.
And from centralized
management, it
means the centralized
form of governance
where the stakeholder engagement
and participation is--
the possibility of stakeholder
engagement is very low.
But when it moves
to the decentralized
form of governance, it can
enclose stakeholder engagement
from local peoples and
local participations.
And in the horizontal
axis, you can
see from the supply
side management
to the demand side management.
In the left upper corner, this
is the traditional development
of water resources management--
not only water resources
management, any development
started from this side.
So it's highly centralized
and supply side approach.
So this is the first development
pattern of water resources.
So for example in this case,
only option is to invest--
how to create dams,
construction, reservoirs.
So this is the only
consideration for the water
resources management.
And it's considered only
engineering-based approach,
and it's very technocratic
approach without considering
societal aspects or
economic aspects--
mainly how to make
the development
and how the development
pattern is start,
and how the
engineering structures
can help to make the
development effective.
So this is the only
consideration in this phase.
And then, so this
is the position
of A in the left-hand
side upper corner.
And but slowly, it moves from
A to B. And in that case,
from investment-oriented
decision, it moves--
it takes consideration of
the societal issues slowly.
And then, so initial
management paradigm
considers mainly engineers,
hydrologists, and technocrats.
But slowly, they can
understand that this can create
consequences to the society.
And they can try to understand
the demand of the local people
slowly.
And so, they try to
incorporate the--
they try to realize
that water is not only
the development pattern
or supply side management.
It needs to consider also
societal and economic aspect.
And thus, the demand
side options is started,
and the demand side
management is started.
And then slowly, it moves
to the C. And in that case,
institutional reformation
start, or for example,
decentralized form of
governance institution.
And yeah, so the--
from engineering-based
structure of the management
paradigm shift towards
different disciplinary bodies
in the management body,
but also local engagement
can also take place.
So this is the overall
broader evolution
of the water
resources management
happens internationally--
and also many countries.
So here I can give an example
how it happens in Bangladesh.
Because I know this--
the context of Bangladesh water
resources management-- how
it happens throughout the time.
So I can also explain the
graph that I have shown
and what happens practically
in the Bangladesh case.
So before 1947, Bangladesh was
part of the British colony.
And during that time,
there is no embankment
to protect flooding
in Bangladesh.
So in that time, local
people manage the embankment
during the dry season
to grow the crops.
And in that case, landlords--
the British empire
provide ownership
to the landlord to manage
a specific area of land.
And to engaging local
farmers, the landlords
was responsible for managing
flood protection embankments
only during the dry
season for growing crops.
But during rainy season,
that embankment was, yeah--
vanished because
of the rainfall.
And the river water could
enter into the flood plain.
And it helps sedimentation.
And it increases the
yeah-- so land formation
was happening during that
time because sediment
could come into the floodplain.
And so this is kind
of a natural process
was maintained
during that period.
But after 1947, the
British colony ended.
And there is no institution
like the landlord management
territory was not there.
And since then, this part of
land was part of Indian estate.
So it was India and
Pakistan was divided.
And Bangladesh was part of the
East Pakistan during that time.
And so during that time, there
is no responsible authority
to managing the
embankment or floodplain.
And during that time
in 1954 and '55,
there was a major flood events.
And after that flood events,
flood protection embankments
was constructed in 1960s.
And you see during that
period heavy engineering works
started.
And in that case, the
embankment protect the flooding
from the river.
But also it helps initially the
agricultural production highly.
But slowly after a
few years, this river
carries a huge
amount of sediment.
And that sediment deposited
in the flood plain,
and that makes the land
formation in the floodplain.
But due to the
embankment, this process
was not taking place due to the
construction of the embankment.
And then the sedimentation
was happening in the riverbed
instead of the floodplain.
So the floodplain--
the land formation
was not happening
in the floodplain.
But those sediment was
deposited in the riverbed.
And that increased the riverbed.
And it reduces the navigability.
At the same time, the internal
water logging is started.
So in 1980s, this whole area of
floodplain becomes waterlogged.
And permanent
flooding was happening
because of this
construction of embankments.
So you see how the consequence
started from the supply side
approach considering only the
narrow focus of the supply side
process.
So initially it
helps in improving
the agricultural production.
But in the long run, it created
a disaster to the local people.
So local people
understood this process.
And they really understood
what is happening there.
So going against
the government, they
tried to cut the embankment
and bring the river
water inside the floodplain.
And this process they call
this, is tidal river management
in 1990s.
So they tried to implement
this process going
against government process.
And they tried to
implement locally
with self-organizing capacity.
And they implemented
it on floodplain.
And they were successful.
And they after two
years, they were
able to see the major
impact, like navigability
in the riverbed is increased.
And also the floodplain--
the sedimentation was
happening in the floodplain.
So then the government could
also see the positive benefits.
So then they tried to
institutionalize this approach
in the government approach.
So you can see how the
transformation or evolution
happened in this context--
a similar explanation
that I just
gave in the previous
slide, just to
show how the evolution
was happening.
I also tried to explain how
a paradigm shift in water
resources management happen
through the literature provided
by Claudia Pahl-Wostl.
She's one of the experts
on adaptive water resources
management or integrated
water resources management.
And so, in her work she tried
to categorize or explain
different dimensions of
water resources management
from command and
control approach
to the integrated approach.
So in the governance dimensions
that the major paradigm shift
happened from centralized
form of governance
to the polycentric form
of governance, which
incorporates both integration
of top-down and bottom-up
approach.
And also in terms of
sectoral integration,
in the case of command and
control approach, in that case,
the sectoral integration
was not possible.
And it creates policy conflicts.
But in the integrated form--
integrated and adaptive form
of management, the
cross-sectoral integration
is possible.
And that also integrates
policy implementation.
So in the case of scale
of analysis and operation,
this transboundary
problems emerge
when rivers or basins
are exclusive scale
of analysis and management.
But in the integrated
form of governance,
the trans boundary issues
addressed by multiple scale
of analysis and management.
And in the case of
information management,
understanding fragmented
by gaps and lack
of integration or proprietary
information sources.
But in the case of integrated
form of governance,
this comprehensive
understanding achieved
by open shared
information sources
that fill gaps and
facilitate integration.
And there are also
three other dimensions.
So as infrastructure,
you can see
that in the first cases,
only the command and control
approach massive
centralized infrastructure
design and engineering
with structure is dominant.
But in the case of integrative
and adaptive water resources
management, this incorporates
a combination of centralized
and decentralized diverse source
of design and power delivery
is very important.
And in terms of financial
and risk management,
this case is only
structural protection.
And these risks are considered.
But in the case of
integrated management,
diversified financial
resources are
considered for by
considering broad set
of private and public
financial instruments.
And important aspect is
dealing with uncertainty.
In the case of command
and control approach,
it is considered
that uncertainty
is considered as undesirable
sign of incomplete knowledge.
So they don't know
what will happen
and how to manage
the uncertainty.
And this will create
major problem.
But adaptive and
integrated management,
the irreducible
uncertainties are acceptable,
and the adaptive
approaches are taken
how to deal with the
future uncertain outcomes
by considering
different scenarios.
For example,
different perspectives
are explicitly acknowledged.
So here you can see difference
between the two approaches
from command and control
to the integrated approach.
So now we would
like to introduce
one of the major paradigm shift
and major dominant paradigm
of water resource management,
which is integrated
water resources management.
And of course, these pulls
in the right-hand side
characteristics that
I have shown here.
So integrative and integrated
water resources management.
Yeah, integrated water
resources management is not new.
Although that is internationally
conceptualized recently
in the 20th century and at
the end of the 20th century
is introduced in the
international arena.
But there are ancient
practices that incorporate--
integrated the major dimensions
of integrated water resources
management has been considered.
For example, in 9th century,
Subak irrigation system in Bali
is one of the ancient
irrigation practices
which practice this integrated
water resources management.
Of course, without
knowing the concept,
but they tried to
incorporate the integration
self-organization for managing
the Bali irrigation systems
through ancient practices.
Here, I wanted to share a
video a very short video--
but you can find
interesting how they
were able to manage
this Subak irrigation
system in the Balinese
agricultural practices.
So let me share this.
You can see how
self-organization
and cooperative water
management has taken place
since that ancient time.
And not only the Subak
system, but also there
are other historical
practices that
incorporates this integrated
form of resource management
practices.
And other water resources
management practices
in Valencia, Spain, the
multi-stakeholder participatory
water tribunal have operated
at least since 10th century.
But also, the modern form of
integrated water resources
management was influenced mainly
by Tennessee Valley Authority
created in 1933 to holistically
manage water resources.
So I don't know whether you
are familiar with the Tennessee
Valley Authority.
Did-- some of you are
familiar with this?
Larry, do you know?
I know some information,
but probably you
know better than me
regarding the TVA
form of management approach.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Well,
TVA wasn't just set up
as a water management body.
The Tennessee Valley
Authority had enormous scope
of development power
and responsibility.
And one of the few times
in the United States
where there was development
across a large region,
more than just a city
or a metropolitan area.
This covered much
more of an area.
And it attempted to
give public management
to infrastructure at a scale
that the United States wasn't
used to.
And as you point out, it was
credited with being a planning
mechanism.
But given how anti-planning the
United States has always been,
I think it's more helpful to
think about it as a development
mechanism.
And we had-- and still
have-- but we had then
lagging regions in terms
of economic development.
And the strategy was, let's
make a massive investment
in a lagging region.
Let's have all of
the infrastructure--
roads that connect it
to other places, water
that it needs, electricity
or hydropower that it needs--
let's have all of
the infrastructure
done simultaneously.
And let's invest government
funding at a large enough scale
that it would then promote
subsequent private investment
and make it a sustainable place
but with a much larger role
for government-managed
infrastructure.
That never took off as an idea.
We don't see other regions
of the United States
where lagging
areas were targeted
by an economic development
strategy that said,
let's have a massive
public investment in all
of the infrastructure,
job creation, training,
and let's not worry about
state and local government.
And let's do it at a scale that
turns around a lagging region.
Because smaller scale efforts
to turn around lagging regions
don't work.
So the way to understand
the TVA story--
and there are many books
written about TVA--
longing for a regional publicly
managed massive infrastructure
project that would stimulate
the economy in a way that
wouldn't happen otherwise.
DR. GAIN: Yeah.
Also, in the IWRM literature
globally, this TVA approach
is highly acknowledged.
And it says that the
TVA-like approach mushroomed
all over the world for mainly
agricultural development
in the developing countries.
So that culture has
been practiced also
in other places, and
regional development plan
through incorporating for
example power generation, flood
control, and how this
integration happens.
And also the concept integration
of multiple sectors in the IWRM
also came from this
TVA-like approach
that is mentioned in
the IWRM literature.
Yeah, so before going
to IWRM principles,
maybe we can have a
participatory discussion here.
Why IWRM is important for water
diplomacy in your opinion.
I wanted to make it
a breakout group.
But as we are only
five people, so maybe
we can discuss why
in your opinion--
also there was a memo on this.
So maybe we can discuss
here why IWRM is
important for water diplomacy.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Well I
guess first, do you think it is?
What is it about integrated
management of water resources
that makes it an important
element of dealing
with trans-boundary waters?
GEMMA HOLT: This is a little
bit of low-hanging fruit.
But one of the readings observed
that it's the dominant paradigm
for water management globally.
So it is therefore
important to diplomacy.
But I think one of the other
things that stood out to me--
and I wrote a little bit
about this in my memo--
is just efforts to move
beyond diplomatic silos.
There was an example
in the Liu et al.
piece that really stood
out to me about biofuels,
and how the
development of biofuels
subsequently catalyzed
or exacerbated
existing problems with
water and food scarcity.
So the need for a more
integrated management approach
felt urgent and
necessary as we move
towards perhaps greater scarcity
in certain water systems.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: But
how would that work?
Or theoretically,
how might that work
in context in which
we do have siloed
entities responsible
for things like water?
And if you say, well,
integrated management
is the key to managing
water in the future
so that you can connect
water with energy, with food,
with land?
But that's not how those
entities are set up.
Gemma Holt: Right.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Aren't we
basically setting up systems
to fail if we say that they have
to be integrated in order to do
water management when we know
that they're not, therefore
what are we hoping for?
GEMMA HOLT: That
was a good question.
I don't know if I have
an immediate answer.
I'll think about that though.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I'm not
sure there's a right answer.
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: It seems
to me that from a planning
perspective-- urban regional
planning perspective,
not a water perspective--
there's always an
argument for centuries
that the way to plan
cities effectively
is to start with
a clean empty area
and have a designer make a
comprehensive integrated plan
so that the land is
used efficiently,
so that all the uses are
appropriately laid out
and separate from each other
when that's appropriate,
and that you don't have
to have holes in the plan
where there's private ownership
or other things that happen.
And you don't have
to worry over time,
because you just started
building in one corner,
and by the time it was done
it was just a giant pattern
of uncontrolled development.
The idea has always been that
you should plan whole cities
in a comprehensive way.
To me, IWRM has some
of the same resonance.
Now we know, in real life there
are very, very few planned
cities where the whole
city was laid out
and all of its evolution
was guided by or controlled
by the original plan.
And it's very hard to have
in a democratic context,
and one in which there's private
land ownership, continuity
with a single plan.
And even in some parts of the
world where historically there
were efforts to plan whole new
capitals, whole new cities,
where they brought in
a famous architect who
made a beautiful plan for
the whole place, over decades
the place changes from
what the original design
was for all kinds of reasons.
Not the least of
which is people want
to have choice about what
things are going to look like,
and what they can do
with what their land is,
and what say they have
in a democratic context.
So just for purposes of
pursuing further the question
that I asked you,
Gemma, is do you
imagine that people in
a democratic context
can live, and work, and build
in a way that's comprehensive,
integrated, and planned when
all the forces of democracy,
privatization,
individuality, and all
the unexpected things
that happen organically
pull in the opposite direction?
GEMMA HOLT: I mean, I
think I have to say, yes,
but that's my prerogative as a
first semester urban planning
student.
If I've already given
up on the field,
then it may be too late for me.
I think that some healthy
skepticism isn't uncalled
for, I guess.
I mean, I don't know.
I guess what is
resonant about IWRM,
and the Water Nexus approach,
and science policy interfaces
more broadly as the
potential to reimagine
existing diplomatic regimes.
But I don't know whether that
actually will work in practice.
So maybe it's just an
intellectual exercise.
But I think it's a useful
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
But it's only useful
if it inspires something in
practice that can be done.
Right?
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
It's not useful
if it alludes to
something in theory that
can't be done in practice,
and everybody's just thwarted
and can't achieve what they're
supposed to-- or the ideal.
And just to loop back around
again to urban planning,
nobody in urban planning teaches
about comprehensive planned
cities anymore except as an
intriguing historical artifact.
Nobody would imagine that you
would build a place according
to a plan at time one
and expect at time two
a decade, two decades,
a century later,
that the place is going to
have anything to do with what
that original plan was.
And yet they still think
there's planning going on.
The planning is about the
process of adaptation.
GEMMA HOLT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
The planning is
to create the institutions
to be able to modify
what you're doing collectively.
So it's still
planning, it's just not
planning to achieve a
preordained comprehensive idea.
And I would argue
in the water realm,
we ought to be worried
about IWRM as an ideal.
Because it presumes
there are institutions
with the authority, the
power, with the knowledge
to integrate across all of
these multiple dimensions,
in spite of the fact that we
have created the silos that you
alluded to, and that there are
contending interests trying
to pursue and maximize
different outcomes that
are good from their standpoint.
So for the reasons I worry
about comprehensive planning--
I worry about IWRM.
DR. GAIN: So any other
thoughts regarding IWRM?
FLORA KLISE: I think something
related to what we were just
talking about is the interesting
fact that in some ways,
the IWRM is very broad.
But then in other
ways, a lot of people
criticize it for not
being broad enough,
saying that the adaptive
water management system needs
to replace or augment the IWRM,
because that is moving toward
that can we not only
create water management,
but can we make sure that this
water management system is also
going to be adaptable
to the future.
Because we have to assume
that it's not constant.
When we look at these extreme
weather patterns, or changes
in the nature of a conflict,
some of these IWRM management
scenarios are just
not actively trying
to adapt and become better
to adjust to these changes.
So in a lot of ways,
people are saying,
oh, the IWRM is not enough.
What about the Nexus?
What about this adaptive
water management system?
And so in my memo,
I talked a lot
about how I think
one of the readings
tried to analyze whether or
not you could replace the IWRM.
And I thought it was
really interesting
that they touched on the
social value of the IWRM.
It's taken a long
time to be adopted,
because a lot of the water
policy water diplomacy sector
is like, if well-respected water
diplomats use a certain water
management system,
then it's more
likely to be used
somewhere else, not just
I guess how some business
models or other sectors
might transfer a certain system.
So I just think that
the IWRM's value,
the fact that it is
water-centric is, I think,
very like a strength
of the IWRM.
And then the fact that
in the Nexus water
is not considered more valuable
or important than these other
sectors that you're
considering in the Nexus,
whether or not it's
the Food Water Energy
Nexus, where every sector
needs to be treated equally.
I think the fact
that the IWRM puts
the water as the most
important entity,
even though it is maybe
creating some boundaries
that the Nexus
wants to get rid of,
I think is still
really valuable.
Because if you get too broad,
it's hard to make any progress.
But maybe I've misinterpreted.
I don't know.
It seems the future
needs to be more
understanding, and
expansive, and multicentric.
But also, how do
we make progress
if we can't get all those
people to sit at the table
and make an agreement
in any regard?
DR. GAIN: Yeah.
I think in terms of
theoretical aspect, of course,
the IWRM is very interesting.
But in terms of practice, this
is the main limitations, that
to implement this theoretical
framework in practice,
this is highly criticized.
And this implementation through
following the actual process
of the framework--
I haven't seen any studies that
really went through the IWRM
implementation.
So that is the main
challenging thing
that the implementation
of IWRM is very difficult,
and it's one of the
unachieved goal of the IWRM.
That's the main criticism.
But in terms of the
theoretical contribution that
has been done, is I think is
highly valuable at the broader
level.
But for implementing, it is kind
of some kind of implementation
oriented approach.
That's how I see.
Any thought around--
AUDIENCE: In practice,
I mean I guess,
in practice I guess
you would hope
that negotiators would
have enough or be
able to bring enough--
I mean, this is obviously
very dependent on what
the kind of initiating
circumstances
are of any negotiation--
but have enough flexibility
to draw upon various
frameworks as needed and as
beneficial to a
specific dispute,
whether or not they
call it IWRM or not.
The limitations of the IWRM
whether it's in terms of scale
or in terms of what's not
included because of its water
centric focus can be
supplemented by drawing off
of some of the other
Nexus approaches
as the others have said
already, that if you
are in the process of
negotiating a dispute,
you ideally should be able to
pick and choose to an extent.
And not be totally
didactic about how
you apply these frameworks.
But I guess, I don't know
how you analyze it then
if you're looking at
it so holistically.
But it's hard for me to
imagine any one framework
being able to
wholly encompass all
of the possibilities
of a water dispute.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
I think starting
with a dispute is going to
get you into a corner you
don't need to be in.
Start with the fact that
you need to manage water.
There's not a dispute.
You just have water, and
you have competing demands,
and you have
competing interests,
and you have to
manage the water.
OK.
What would be a good
way to manage the water?
To involve entities with
broad authority or multiple
authorities, or narrow--
just water, to involve
only the most expert
people to make the decisions,
or to engage the stakeholders
affected by the
decisions so there's
support for whatever the
decision is to go ahead with.
Would it make more sense to
look just narrowly at the water
that you have
responsibility for,
because you're within
a political boundary,
or would it make more sense to
look at the water system moving
underground or above ground
that affects the water that you
have responsibility for?
Because the answers to those
three kinds of questions
almost always lead
to people saying,
broader, linked,
more comprehensive,
more participatory,
more completely
engaged, because it seems like
a better way to manage water.
Now, assume there's a dispute
within that water management
system.
How would you expect
it to be resolved?
Well, if you had pulled
in all of those actors,
and all of those interests,
and all of that knowledge,
and all of that authority
to manage the water,
and there was a
dispute within that,
you'd probably have to engage
all of those same elements
in sorting out a
dispute that emerged.
It would be hard to say,
oh, there's a dispute.
Now all of you who were
involved in the planning of this
and the management
of this, go away.
And the three of
us will solve this.
It's not going to happen.
So IWRM isn't a dispute
resolution mechanism.
IWRM is an approach
to water management.
And when disputes
come up, it's all
tangled up in the dispute
resolution process
because of what
it took to do IWRM
as the planning-- as
the management scheme.
It was never meant to
be a dispute resolution
strategy or mechanism.
But it's tangled up with
efforts at dispute resolution.
Because it's kind of hard to
shrink any of the dimensions--
the parties, the interest,
the scope of the problem,
the institutional powers--
for purposes of
resolving a dispute
that's come up within
the IWRM process.
AUDIENCE: Within models, I mean,
could you differentiate and say
the initial--
as you said, anyone who thinks
through the three questions you
asked is going to move out and
say, broader, more inclusive,
greater scope for this.
Could you differentiate
and say, OK,
the initial water
management considered
negotiations will exist
on this macro level
and incorporate many different
facets of the economy
and secondary, tertiary
effects of water management.
But then you say after that,
you basically incorporate
dispute resolution
processes that
are hyper-local, that are
specific to the area where
the resolution-- where
the dispute is taking
place, and don't require
completely remapping
all of the old terrain?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
That historically,
that's what the law and
regulation have in fact done.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: We have
a system of water rights
that has nothing
to do with IWRM.
Just take California or take
the Western United States.
IWRM, you would plan that
water in a certain way.
But you can't in a system
that's defined senior water
rights, where people who got
there first got the water.
And nobody can tell
them what to do with it.
And they can waste it, they
can do anything they want.
It's completely contrary
to the ideas of IWRM.
And until relatively
recently, the whole water law
around the world is not
connected to water management.
The rules of water law come
down almost in the way, Aaron,
you're describing.
Just how can I localize this,
and situate it in the way
we deal with other
property rights,
and that's how we'll
handle the dispute.
But it doesn't fit
with what we imagine
is the broader
scope, and the need
to take account
of more interests,
and the desire to look at the
interconnectedness of things,
and the need to look ahead--
not back at who had
what rights, but forward
in terms of who has what needs.
And yet we're stuck with it.
So again, IWRM is a water
management approach.
It's easy to see how it evolved.
And it seems perfectly logical.
And it doesn't offer
an obvious or easy way
of handling disputes
over water within systems
that are managed by IWRM.
And if you just try to
solve this water disputes
in a purely legal
fashion that determines
who has what senior
rights, and hey, that's it.
It's property.
But that doesn't
take account of water
as a shared human resource
or as a human right.
And now, how do
we solve disputes
over the allocation of water?
We can't use the
property rights law.
We need something else.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that makes sense.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
And Animesh, how do you
react to what I just said?
DR. GAIN: Yeah, so in terms of
relation with IWRM and water
diplomacy, I see that
IWRM says, according
to IWRM principal
or dimensions, water
should be managed in a
transboundary, or watershed,
or ecological boundary.
So in that case, I
can see the relation
with IWRM and water diplomacy.
Because when I say
that water should
be managed in a watershed
or transboundary scale,
that means it definitely crosses
boundary of ecological boundary
with the political boundary.
And it can immediately creates
institutional mismatches.
And that can be managed through
a-- a water diplomacy approach.
So there's how I can see
a relation with IWRM.
So I can see water
diplomacy can be
useful for the difficulties that
have IWRM implementation can be
somehow implemented through
incorporating water diplomacy
approach.
That's how I feel the relation
of IWRM and water diplomacy.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Do you
want to go to your next slide
and look at the
principles of IWRM
explicitly in light of the
general discussion we've had?
DR. GAIN: Yeah.
So these are just a historical
perspective of IWRM.
So according to-- so it is
started from the UN conference
on water in Mar
del Plata in 1977.
Then in 1992, Dublin
conference, which
is the main building block for
developing the IWRM principles.
And in this conference,
these four principles
has been considered.
So the principle number
one is the freshwater
is finite and
vulnerable resources
essential to sustain
life, development,
and the environment.
So here you can
compare the thinking
of the water diplomacy.
So it's completely opposite
of the thinking of the Dublin
principle or water diplomacy
framework considered
water is the flexible
resource instead
of finite and
vulnerable resource.
So how the conflicting
situation can
be considered as the
cooperative thinking
that can be a major shift of
thinking in terms of principles
of IWRM and water diplomacy.
So in terms of
principle number two,
water diplomacy and
management should
be based on a participatory
approach involving
users, planners, and
policymakers at all levels.
And another important
principle is
that women should be a part of
the decision-making process,
like prohibition, management,
and safeguarding of water.
Specifically considering
the role of women
in the developing country,
how they are closely involved
with the water resource
management and services
of the water resources.
And the fourth and
final principle
is that water has an economic
value in all its components--
recognized as an
economic resource.
So these are the four principles
of Dublin conference in 1992.
And then another event where
IWRM was first established
is Second World Water Forum
and Ministerial Conference
in The Hague, where it's
considered that equity
criteria along with subsidiary--
um, subsidies to poor.
This is also considered
as a principle of IWRM.
And then it is declared in
the International Conference
on Freshwater in Bonn, 2001.
And then World Summit on
Sustainable Development
in 2002.
So now, based on
these principles,
IWRM has been, as you can
see from the global water
partnership definition
that IWRM is considered
as a process which promotes
the coordinated development
and management of water,
land, and related resources,
in order to maximize the
resultant economic and social
welfare in an equitable manner,
and without compromising
the sustainability of
the vital ecosystems.
So it incorporates
theoretically multiple aspects,
like it is considered
as a planning process,
as Larry already mentioned,
and it incorporates
the coordinated
development, like TVA kind
of development pattern, which
incorporates not only water
resources, but also water
and related resources that
are linked with water
can be managed together
for maximizing the economic and
social welfare with an equity
basis of considering
the sustainability
of the ecosystems.
So that is the broader
definition of IWRM.
And probably, you have read in
this criticism by Asit Biswas.
And where he mainly criticized
the Hague definition
of integration, what issues
needs to be integrated,
and how it can be a process.
And so, in terms of
operational point of view,
he identified this vagueness.
And in terms of theory is fine.
But in terms of
implementation, how this can
be applied in a given context--
this is completely vague.
That's what his message
is broadly regarding IWRM.
So we tried to identify
main dimensions of IWRM.
So these are the [INAUDIBLE]
dimensions that in our studies
that we try to identify.
So first [INAUDIBLE] dimension
is integrated management.
And the second dimension is
the river basin or watershed
should be the special skill
for managing water resources.
And water governance or
institutional mechanism
for governing water
is very important.
And involving a stakeholders
and public participation
is also one of the key
dimensions of IWRM.
And consideration of
water as an economic good
is an important
consideration of IWRM.
And also ensuring gender
equity and social capital
is one of the main dimensions.
So these are the seven
dimensions of the IWRM.
And here I can see as I
was mentioning, that river
basin as a spatial scale.
And to implement
this river basin
for water resources management,
it certainly creates conflict.
And for managing
that, water diplomacy
can play an important role
for managing water resources.
For integrated management,
there are criticisms
that needs to be integrated.
And that also depends
on the specific context.
And a specific context
by engaging stakeholders
what issues needs to be
integrated can be decided
and can be considered in
a negotiation table that
can be part of the
implementation part of IWRM
through a water
diplomacy approach.
So that's how I consider
that for implementing IWRM--
the criticism that
has in the literature.
Some of the criticism can
be overcome when we consider
the water diplomacy approach.
That's just how I see.
I don't know.
Larry, what would
be your opinion
on the linkage between
IWRM and water diplomacy?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Well,
I thought your description
was very reasonable.
I start with the
problems in practice.
And maybe that's why I'm
less tolerant of some
of the fuzziness and some of
the ambiguity in IWRM the way
it's been written about
and the way it emerged.
I mean, calling water
an economic good leads
to the notion that you
should get the prices right
if you want to protect
the environment,
if you want to
protect the water.
But as soon as you start talking
about getting the prices right,
you're assuming
water is a commodity.
And if you think water
should be a right,
then the price is not relevant.
And thinking of it as an
economic good is not helpful.
And some of you know I'm
working on the problem of water
shutoffs in American
cities, where
people who can't pay
their bill for their water
for a month or two have
their water shut off.
Well, they can't pay their bill
because they're out of work.
And telling them they
have to pay their bill
isn't going to make it possible
for them to pay their bill.
And then the next thing that
the water department does
is it calls the Family
Services department
and says, take the
children out of that home.
There's no water there.
It's not hygienic.
So their kids are taken away.
They still can't pay the bill.
And then the next thing that
happens is the city puts--
sells the lien-- it's
an economic instrument
on the debt--
because the city
needs money to pay
to maintain the water system.
And if people don't
pay their bills,
it doesn't have the money.
It can't maintain the system.
So it sells the debt to
private moneylenders, who
then come after the person
on a daily basis and saying,
not only do you owe us the $900
from the last four months, now
the interest rate--
and we've just
increased it to 10% interest.
They can't pay the debt,
they can't pay the interest.
And then after a
year the city says,
we're going to sell your house
to recoup the mounting debt.
We have all kinds of
cities in the United States
where the water authority sells
liens and forecloses on homes,
all because people couldn't
pay the fee for water
because they lost their job.
Now, we have laws that don't
allow the electricity company
to turn off electricity
in the winter
if you can't pay your bill,
because the presumption
is you'll die.
But we don't have
comparable laws
that say you can't shut
off people's water.
Now during COVID,
very interestingly,
we have had a moratorium on
water shutoffs in some cities.
Because now the
presumption is, people
have a good excuse for being
unable to pay their bills.
But before somehow, they
didn't have an excuse,
like they lost their job.
This is all a
function of thinking
of water as an economic good.
What if we said, every
residential property
gets a certain minimum
amount of water
that you need to stay alive
that doesn't cost anything.
And then all the
water above that,
you pay a price relative
to your ability to pay.
Well, we never had
in the United States
a system of water fees based on
ability to pay until last year
when Philadelphia passed the
first municipal law saying
that they wanted to move
in a different direction
and have people pay for
some portion of their water
relative to their
ability to pay.
And you can imagine the legal
battle that's now ongoing about
whether that's OK or not.
But all of that stems from the
idea that water is a commodity,
and we should have
to buy and sell it.
In Australia, when it saw that
it was running out of water--
fresh water, and had all
terrible forest fires
and other difficulties--
bought as a government all
the water rights in one state
back from the owners at a
prevailing price per hectare.
And then it paid back the
money by selling back the water
rights but on a
different basis to people
to try to have greater equity
in the availability of water.
So it built a whole system based
on water as an economic good
in order to address
a common need.
Where if we thought of
water as a natural resource
and as a common resource,
pricing wouldn't be the focus.
And we've tried to
make a market out
of everything in the Western
capitalist countries.
And so now we have
problems of water
being unavailable to
different groups of people.
And I worry that IWRM is
about maximizing water
as an economic good.
That's one of the
seven principles
or whatever that
you had listed--
water is an economic good.
And there are several
of the principles
I understand completely
where they came from.
But when I look in
practice, the problem
is we have underinvestment
in the capital
improvements necessary to get
water to people that need it.
And there's not a way to solve
that through integrated water
resource management.
That's a political,
ethical, moral decision.
So a lot of the
conflicts, some of which
don't rise to the level
of a formal conflict
because the poor, the
disadvantaged, the marginalized
don't have the political
clout to make it a fight.
But in fact, there's a conflict
with very large numbers
of people in different
parts of the world
unable to get adequate
water, because there's no way
to pay the capital cost to
build the desalination plant,
to build the water movement
system to get water
from one place to another.
So that's what I worry about
IWRM causing conflict and not
providing a pathway
to resolution
of conflicts given some of
the principles it includes.
HUSNAIN AFZAL: Yeah.
I had a different perspective
to what you just said.
For example, if a poor
person in my country
doesn't have access
to clean water,
he's installing a
hand pump or something
at the cost of
$1,000 or something,
it's an additional burden
to his daily income.
What if the state would have
provided him a water supply
network with a certain
pricing, and the state
had ensured that that water
was clean enough to drink?
For example, I in Pakistan can't
drink water directly from tap.
I'm not sure about drinking
water directly from the tap.
But here in my
residence in Ithaca,
I drink water
directly from the tap.
So by this, I'm saving money
from the bottled water,
and then I'm saving
money for installing
my own boiling system
or pumping system.
So if the state provided
me with clean water
with certain price in
which they are maintaining
the infrastructure, which
is lesser than the amount
which I am spending back
home on bottled water
and boiling water cost, like
[INAUDIBLE] or something
like that, then don't you
think that the approach would
be much better-- the water
pricing approach would
be better in this scenario?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: You're
paying rent in Ithaca
that includes water cost.
And if you lived
in Flint, Michigan,
you would be paying not
that much different rent,
but you couldn't drink
the water from the tap,
because it's been allowed
to become contaminated.
And the city doesn't
have the resources
to rebuild the whole system.
So we've pushed
on to individuals
the cost of getting
water in some cities
whether we've allowed the
water to become contaminated.
Maintaining clean water is,
I would argue, a common cost
not an individualized cost.
While you can go buy
water in bottles,
we still expect the availability
of clean water from the tap--
drinkable water that
won't kill you--
to be a common cost.
If it's a common cost, then
we should collect taxes
from everybody in
a progressive way
and take care of building
the things that are common,
like clean water system.
So I know--
I heard the comparison
you're making.
But I would argue both in
Pakistan and in the United
States, that responsibility
of local government
should be to provide
drinkable water for people
as a capital cost that's
a collective cost.
And whether that cost
is paid for from taxes,
which could be collected
in a progressive way,
or fees, which typically
are not collected
in a progressive way--
they don't look at
ability to pay--
I think we can have that debate
about what's the fair way
to collect the money.
But once the money
is collected, it
should be used to get
everybody a minimum amount
of clean water.
That's my argument.
DR. GAIN: Yeah.
And I think that also fits
with the IWRM principle
like social equity and yeah.
So--
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
Well, basically--
HUSNAIN AFZAL: And to add
to your point, that I mean,
if IWRM is a
collective approach,
it's not about governments only.
It's about people also--
society, societal education.
For example, if you're
doing-- you just
said-- used the word
"contamination."
Who is doing contamination?
We are doing contamination.
We are mixing sewage
water with water.
We are doing water taps.
We are doing hole to the
main water supply line
to get more water for ourselves.
That is something related
to the societal education.
If we do not educate
people that water should
be treated as a
precious resource,
that it should not
be contaminated,
it's like a joint
responsibility,
not the responsibility
of government only.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I agree.
I agree.
You'll have to excuse me.
I'm trying desperately to get
the folks planning Glasgow
to approach the problem
in a different way
than they did in Paris.
And they have chosen this hour.
At least I have a
chance to talk to them.
I'm not making any progress.
This is the third try.
But I feel obliged--
if they just meet in
Glasgow and do again
what they did in
Paris, we are doomed.
And there has to be a
different discussion.
And there's a
group of us who are
trying to promote a
different global discussion
on this question.
So I'm going to disappear.
But the conversation
about IWRM is important,
because you need-- each of you--
needs to formulate-- to
take a stand, to formulate
an idea, of how you think
water should be managed,
and how you think disputes
over the management of water
should be resolved.
And I don't think
either Animesh or I
thinks we know all the answers.
And I don't think
there's only one solution
for all places and all times.
But we need to be
thinking prescriptively.
And if the best language
we could say is,
social needs are important.
Common goods should
be taken into account.
Water should be managed in
a comprehensive fashion.
Look at the linkage between
water and everything else.
I don't think that
inspires action or policy.
I think it's too vague.
So I'm pushing you to
think in more explicit
prescriptive terms,
and then to be
able to argue for
it-- for that view.
HUSNAIN AFZAL: And before you
leave, can you just tell me
the questions you are going
to address in this meeting?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Yes.
What should be done
before the meeting
by the people who will
be coming to the meeting
while they can still
formulate new policy choices.
Because once you're at
the meeting, all you do
is argue about the text
that's been sent out.
And every 197 delegations
have been sent there
with very explicit
instructions by their country.
There's no problem-solving
that can happen at the meeting.
But before the meeting,
everyone is busy
figuring out what they
want everybody else to do.
There's no joint
planning beforehand,
because it can't be
done in an official way.
If it's done in an official
way, then everybody's
there reading the script
from their country,
saying everybody
else is responsible,
this is a problem,
that's a problem--
nothing can happen.
So we're trying to get a
different kind of conversation
amongst a substantial
number of the people who
will be at the
conference representing
their countries
into conversations
between now and the summer--
not in their official
capacity, just
in terms of problem-solving.
And not just technical,
the others as well.
But people say, well, how would
you decide who participates?
And my argument is,
it doesn't matter.
They're not going
to decide anything.
They're just going to put
forward good proposals.
Let's just have a
diverse group that
wants to put forward proposals
in the collective interest.
Well, where would you have it?
When would you have it?
I said, it doesn't matter.
We'd do it online.
We just need to start
work on new proposals
of a different kind.
And the question that I'm
saying that the proposals should
be about--
what help does your country
need to get to net zero by 2030?
Not what's your responsibility
for cutting stuff.
What help do you say you need
to get to net zero by 2030?
And collect that, and
look at the differences
amongst what countries
say they want and need.
And then figure out
how different countries
can help each other work
toward that as the goal.
2030 net zero, that's
what we have to aim for.
But now all we have is how
much of the overrun will
you agree to accept no
matter what it costs you.
And the answer is, you
can't make me do it.
And that's Paris.
And we're going to get
it again in Glasgow.
So that's the conversation
I'm trying to promote.
Forgive me.
DR. GAIN: Yeah.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I will
see you all next week.
DR. GAIN: [LAUGHS] So Mashroof,
you wanted to say something?
Maybe quickly, because we
only have half an hour left.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN:
[INAUDIBLE] that
is I agree with Larry's
argument that there should
be a minimum amount of
water for every household
or every person, instead of
putting them extreme pressure
through the capitalist system.
This is I completely agree.
But at the same time,
in my country I've seen,
and probably you have seen also,
that when something is free,
or whatever the amount that is,
when something is free, most
of the people--
and that is I have seen
from my observation,
and I'm sure that the
research if anyone does it
would give the same data--
that when something is free,
there is a tendency to waste.
And in Bangladesh or in
a developing country,
a huge number of people--
they would be not that
rich to afford it.
So the government would be
giving them a massive amount
of water in total.
And if everybody
wastes just a little,
or the majority of the
people waste just a little,
that's a huge amount
of water being
wasted, just because it's free.
And just because
it's free, people
do not value it that much.
So I was thinking that how do we
make a mechanism to stop that.
Is there any mechanism at all?
So that was my question.
DR. GAIN: Yeah.
I think that in terms
of IWRM, in principle
the mechanism is there.
So we need to place
a price on the water.
And yeah, one equity
versus the price
could be different for
different group of people.
And that can help
efficiency of water use.
And just that is demand side
management of water resources
that is needed for increasing
water use efficiency.
So yeah, the mechanism is there
in terms of theoretical aspect.
But for implementing
in Bangladesh
or in specific countries is--
yeah, there are problems.
So maybe now we can discuss
Water Energy and Food Nexus,
the still we need to--
so Water Energy and Food Nexus.
This is another
important paradigm
of water resources management.
Sometimes it's called
separate paradigm.
But sometimes it's within
integrated water resources
management, where
the integration was
big in the IWRM.
And in this case, this
central integration
is explicitly mentioned.
Like [INAUDIBLE] integration
of water, energy, and food.
But it could be also water,
energy, food, climate, water,
energy, climate, ecosystem.
So it depends on the context.
But thinking of the Nexus is it
comes from system integration.
So how the global systems
are interconnected,
and how the traditional
silo approaches
is diminishing the importance
of system level outcome.
And that's why the
Nexus concept came.
So for example,
if I ask you what
you have eaten in the
breakfast, maybe a banana.
And in that banana
is not only food,
but also it incorporates
huge amount of water
for producing the banana,
but also transportation,
and also from the
agricultural field
to coming into the
food breakfast table,
it consumes huge
amount of energy.
And if you don't--
if you waste that
banana, then you
can calculate how much
energy and water has also
been wasted from producing too.
So this kind of thinking
is the Nexus thinking.
So if you can increase the
efficiency of water use
in one sector, that can also
helps increasing efficiency
in the energy sector
and also food sector.
And that's how the
Water Energy Food Nexus
concept came, not only in
the household perspective,
not only in the urban
aspect, but also
in the transboundary water
resources management aspect.
So the Nexus concept builds
on many of this process.
And it also incorporates
this integrated process.
But I already
shared this article.
Probably you have
read this article.
And it's interesting,
because it clearly
identifies the synergies and
trade-offs of water resources
management within Water
Energy and Food Nexus,
and how the incorporating
Nexus thinking
can help increase the efficiency
of water resources management.
So for example,
this Nexus thinking
can uncover synergies
and co-benefits.
The example that is given in
the London urine separation
technology that helps reducing
10% of water needs reduction,
but also eventually
this also helps
reducing energy
use in water supply
by 10% and wastewater
treatment by 25%.
So by using simple urine
separation technology,
that this helps reducing
water needs, energy needs,
and wastewater treatment.
But also it helps
capturing nutrients.
For example, 2,300
tons of phosphorus
and 24,000 tons of
nitrogen annually
can be separated that can
be utilized for producing
a million tons of wheat in UK.
So you can see how the
synergies and co-benefits
can be achieved by applying
this Water Energy Food Nexus
approach.
But also, it can detect
harmful trade-off.
For example, in Egypt and Spain,
the water demand comparison
is 75% higher than
Spain in Egypt.
But because in
Egypt, it considers
gravity-oriented
irrigation system,
which requires much water.
But at the same time,
the energy consumption
is three times lower
than the Spain.
Because in Spain, it considers
not the gravity irrigation,
but energy drip and
drip irrigation systems.
So if we convert the
irrigation system in Egypt,
then the water is saved.
But at the same time, the energy
and carbon dioxide production
rate has increased
significantly.
So this kind of trade-off can
be considered by considering
this Nexus approach.
And also, I think Gemma was
mentioning about the biofuels.
And here is the
example of biofuel,
how the increased
consumption of biofuel
is promoted as an
alternative of oil and gas.
But at the same time, it
can create huge amount
of water scarcity and food
sustainability in the United
States, but also in
the other countries.
So the unexpected
consequences can
be taken into account by
considering this Nexus
approach.
So also in terms of integrated
planning, and decision-making,
and governance, this
Water Energy Food Nexus
is very important.
Let's consider the
transboundary aspect.
So here in terms of
Water Energy and Food
Nexus in the
transboundary context,
if you see the relation
between water and food.
And for the food production,
you must need water.
And in the upstream, water
uses for the agriculture
affects also in the downstream.
And this can-- so
the water and food
are highly relevant in
that transboundary context.
But also, food affect
water resources.
For example, it can
through intensifying
agricultural practices
and land use changes
by agricultural expansion,
this can affect water quantity
by changing the runoff.
But also it can affect
eutrophication and salinization
and affects water quality.
But at the same time, if you
see the relation between water
and energy, for the energy
production, of course
you need water.
And energy production
also affects water quality
and quantity.
For example, the hydropower
production for energy
affects on water quality
in terms of changing water
temperature.
And also, so the
water temperature
can change quickly by
storing water in a dam.
And that can also affect
changing the water quality
parameter.
So you can see
that these linkages
are important for
transboundary context.
In this study done
by Keskinen et al,
they tried to compare
three transboundary areas
in the Central Asia, mainly
the Aral Sea, South Asian
context, Ganges-Brahmaputra,
and in the Mekong region--
the Mekong River basin.
And they tried to
qualitatively analyze
this interrelation between
the water, energy, and food.
And the thickness
of the line can
determine how the
relationship established,
and what are the strength of
the relationships are determined
by the thickness of the line.
For example, in the
case of Central Asia,
the impact of food on water
is highly important there.
But also impact of energy
production on downstream water
flow is also important.
In the case of South
Asia, the impact of--
the importance of water
on agricultural production
between the upstream and
downstream is very important.
So that's how they found.
So this kind of
qualitative relationships
for water resources management
within the Water Energy Food
Nexus has been established.
So in terms of how the
Water Energy Food Nexus is
important for water diplomacy.
So as you have seen, that
the identifying synergies
and trade-offs beyond
water and river basin
management [INAUDIBLE]
is providing
a scope for water diplomacy.
But also the mutual benefit
and promoting value creation--
the Water Energy Food Nexus
gave a clear value added
for water negotiation.
For example, hydropower--
linking hydropower,
agricultural production, and
water management can help
saving--
that can help creating
multiple benefits,
and multiple co-benefits,
and multiple value that helps
water negotiation very easily.
But also, Water Energy Food
Nexus promote business idea.
And that can also link
into the negotiation table,
and can help reducing
the conflict,
and can create a
cooperative environment.
So these are the ideas
that Water Energy Food
Nexus can support promoting
the water diplomacy.
That's how I see it.
So here is a reference.
I'll put them in
the Canvas site.
I found just recently, so
I can share this article,
so that you can have an
understanding how Water Energy
Food Nexus can be useful
for water diplomacy.
And also, how
water diplomacy can
help implementing Water
Energy Food Nexus approach.
Just quickly, sustainable
development goals--
the sustainable development
goal has been considered in 2015
to meet the target by 2030.
And in order to move
from MDGs to SDGs,
it considers 17 SDGs
and with 169 targets.
And SDG 6 is the ensuring
availability and sustainable
management of water
and sanitation for all.
And it incorporates
SDG 6.5 that we
need to implement IWRM through
transboundary cooperation.
So the goal 6.5, or
target 6.5 specifically
on implementation of IWRM
for cooperation incorporating
transboundary cooperation.
So here is the linkage
of SDGs and IWRMs.
But also the way IWRM is
considered as an indicator,
it is kind of--
there is criticism
on this, because IWRM
is very broader concept
and theoretical concept.
But the way that
IWRM is considered
as even sustainable goals, there
is strong criticism on that.
Because it considers very vague
way of putting numbers on IWRM.
And how the measuring the
progress is very debatable.
But this is one of the major
paradigm that internationally
acknowledged.
And that's why IWRM
is very important.
And also with relation to
SDGs and water diplomacy,
I see that many SDG
goals are interlinked.
And it can creates
synergies and trade-offs.
So for example, if I can
make one SDG target of,
for example, renewable
energy production.
And for renewable
energy production,
is not specifically defined
which kind of renewable energy
can be produced.
So that can promote the idea
of hydroelectric electricity
generation.
So that can also affect
implementation of IWRMs.
Because if you promote upstream
water development projects
for hydroelectricity, then
this can affect relationship
with the downstream countries.
So these kind of synergies and
trade-offs are very important.
And that can be
reduced, or that can
be resolved through
diplomacy approach broadly.
So that's how I can see
the link between the SDGs
and the water diplomacy
aspect in general.
So that's we wanted to
discuss today classes.
So first, we already
discussed the evolution
of water resources management,
how it came from the supply
side approach to the demand
and decentralized approach
with an example.
But then, we already discussed
IWRM and its importance
in the international water
resource management aspect,
and its relation with
the water diplomacy.
But also, we discussed
Water Energy Food Nexus
and sustainable development
goals, and its relation
with water diplomacy.
Yes, so the next class
will be the week after.
And that class we'll play
a role-play simulation,
practically how we can
resolve water conflicts.
We'll play the game Indopotamia
river basin management.
And for the
role-play simulation,
we will need nine players.
But we have six players.
So do you know is there
any of your friend
could be interested in
the role-play simulation?
If you don't find, I will try
to find three other players.
But if you have
interesting colleagues that
are highly interested to
understand the role-play game,
you can let me know.
Yeah.
So another notice
or announcement
is that next week,
Larry and me are
going to talk on transboundary
water resources management.
Larry will discuss mainly
the theoretical aspect.
And I will describe the
Brahmaputra River basin case.
So if you are interested,
you can join in this event.
I can share the link
for the presentation.
It's the EU time.
So it's the European time.
So in US time, this
would be 11 AM.
Or yeah.
So if you are interested, feel
free to join in this event.
Yeah.
Oh, another
announcement-- sorry,
I wanted to put it in here.
There is a discussion paper on
Water Energy and Food Nexus.
And there is a discussion
series is taking place
by one of our colleague, who
is the editor of the journal
Hydrological Sciences Journal.
And in that discussion
paper, there
is a topic on Water
Energy and Food Nexus.
And people are
interested, and if you
feel is fit in your
area of interest,
there is a paper on water
quality and Water Energy Food
Nexus.
And if you can criticize
or comment on that paper,
that can also be published if
this is a concise and yeah,
written in a scientific way.
So I can share that link if you
are interested in participating
this kind of writing.
You can let me know.
I have the linkage with
the editor of that journal.
So I can share with you
if you are interested.
So the writeup should
be one or two pages,
but it should be written
in a scientific way.
Yeah.
So I shared those two links.
And also I will share
the role-play simulation,
what the general
instruction, but also
a confidential instruction
for each player.
I will share it with you
in the next few days.
Yeah.
So bye.